I will agree 100% it is difficult to tax
rich people it is very very very
difficult to tax rich people I don't I
don't come here saying I want to tax
rich people because it's easy I know
it's hard I know probably I'm going to
lose I know our viewers kids will live
in Desperate poverty I know that I do
this because it is hard if we are a
country which says to ourselves we don't
try and do things which are necessary to
keep our kids out of poverty because
they are hard then our kids will live in
poverty I don't need to be here I'm a
multimillionaire just like you I could
be in the Philippines drinking panac
coladas I come in here because I come
from a poor background and it's ordinary
families like my family like the kids I
grew up with whose kids are going to be
in poverty it's difficult but it is
necessary sometimes we have to do things
not because they're easy but because
they are hard that is what makes a rich
country rich and that is what protects
ordinary people listen our grandparents
lived in poverty did they say let's not
change it because it's hard no they
didn't they fought and they demanded
they demanded Health Care education
housing food and they got it they got it
that's why my parents could live a good
quality life they got those things they
got those things and they were aware
that in order to do that you could not
allow the super rich who have been
living lives of luxury for hundreds and
hundreds of years to eat everything
while ordinary families couldn't afford
to feed their kids I know it's difficult
I know it's difficult and I know I'm
probably going to lose I know that I
know I'm probably going to lose and that
means our viewers will be poor but I do
it anyway because I do not want this
this country that I grew up in to fall
into desperate poverty